now to ukraine where russia has
intensified its attacks on the eastern
and southern parts of that country and
the ukrainians they are fighting back
this video from the russian military
claims to show damage in russian
occupied territory charlie dagetta went
to the ukrainian front lines and spoke
to some of those who are fighting
including an american veteran
explosions rocked the southern city of
kirsan overnight
residents have been protesting the
russian occupation
and ukraine has made clear it has no
intention of giving it up
still trapped beneath the steel plant in
mariopol a ukrainian officer pleads for
an evacuation of hundreds
the war has become a brutal artillery
battle waged along a jagged front in
southern and eastern ukraine where we
visited the front lines
as you can see this is a freshly dug
trench and it's a fallback position for
ukrainian soldiers who've been defending
the russian advance not far from here
the commander told us the fighting has
been so intense the russians launched
1500 mortars on a single position in a
single day
special forces battalion commander igor
lapin said they simply do not have the
firepower to match russia
the biggest difficulty is that we're
running short on high caliber ammunition
he said the military is always hungry
for ammo
and hungry for experienced warriors like
iraq war marine veteran and alaska
native joshua cropper you're willing to
put your life on the line for another
country
yes sir what is it like fighting beside
these ukrainian forces i wish that they
had a more nato experience more nato
training
but uh more nato weapons more nato
weapons but their their hearts in the
right place and their convictions in the
right place
former royal air force serviceman jordan
davis left a five-year-old daughter back
home in the uk uh you realize you're
about as close as you can get to the
front line are you prepared for what may
happen absolutely you're willing to die
i am willing to die here if needs be
that position was within easy reach of
russian artillery and russian forces are
closing in on three sides the ukrainian
commander told us they haven't received
any of america's heavy weapons at that
location yet
tony all right charlie daggett in
ukraine for us once again charlie thank
you very much